I love I love that there's just like no
rules in Texas
what do you mean what I mean there
definitely is I just mean like it's like
everything's so everything's like so
careful in California I always had the
surface compared to California
everywhere it has no [ __ ] rules yeah
like that's what I'm saying like like
there was no there you signed one waiver
and then it was like okay you're on your
own for like four hours yeah like it's a
dangerous thing I pulled my back yeah
because I got slammed on the bottom so
hard there was not once where they were
like yeah you should try and fall like
this in California be like okay make
sure that they make you sign 500 waivers
everyone like shoes out here exactly
back there was like whatever you're on
your own go if you get hurt it's [ __ ]
your and if you would have messaged me I
would have told you go to pinballs
what's that to why trash Dave and
Busters that's fair see that sounds
awesome inside of pinballs there's a
go-kart track
I told you about it already
you did not I did I have better memory
than you and I wouldn't remember 100 I
better remember because you messaged me
while I was drunk at pinballs at one
time you're like hey man I'm in Kansas
City I'm in your old stomping grounds
and I was peeing on your childhood home
and I was like I'm gonna buy this that's
cool I don't care it smells like piss
anyways and I'd be like and he was just
like can I do anything I remember you
were like I'm in Austin and I remember
being like pinballs go to pinballs
go-kart track I can't man I gotta get to
bed early and all this kind of other
stuff oh you know why because I I went
to the Circuit of the Americas and I
drove the car track there I also feel
like every time oh yeah that's what it
was because also every time you go the
last I think the other time you saw the
F1 race yeah of course sorry what can I
say what do you think about English
celebs there too what do you think about
his F1 do you have some like rich boy
like Hobbies like I like golf a lot he
makes fun of me for that apparently
they're like sailing he liked sailing
for one day and I made fun of him for
that too no I liked watching the sailing
documentaries oh that's right yeah you
like sailing for one day that's true and
I didn't say I just I I like the only
reason I opened Twitter anymore is to
see if Noel has any hot takes on the F1
circuit yeah as if anybody knows
anything about hey hey there's like
[ __ ] 12 people can you believe that
guy got robbed in the race or whatever
man it's crazy everyone's just like no
not at all dude you're [ __ ] I also
love being at your house watching you
watch the race he's just like
Alina's just on the couch just like
yep yep
tacos man
complaining you're the tallest racer at
your track and stuff like that yeah
because you have to be the size of like
a jockey to even race in Evelyn
the tallest person that races F1 is five
foot one you want to put that to the
test you wanna put money on that I would
realistically I would say five eight
honestly honestly I think so how tall is
uh let's pull up George Russell what
about [ __ ] Lewis Louie he's five nine
oh my God yep how do you know that man
because he's in love with him
really yeah you're in love with him yeah
why because he's a great racer I just
respect his craft no I want to be him
he's the he's the easiest life really he
dude he's been driving the fastest car
on Earth for the last like eight years
uh good looking dude makes like a
hundred bazillion dollars a year untaxed
every day he posted untaxed because he
lives in Monaco
Monaco his stories are it's a joke like
that dude lives life on creative mode
like one day he'll be like I'm in Africa
with my friends and he'll be having a
private dinner on like the Serengeti and
the next day he'll be buying out a
vintage video game store in a different
country I'm like you just you just do
whatever that [ __ ] is unreal yeah
I'm just saying like the spectrum of the
things that he does it's just funny
you want to know I got one of the best
gifts wait no no hold on we got a
birthday well it's kind of related to
this but yes please six one six one okay
so yeah you can be tall and racing F1
but you're right it is a petite Man
sport one of the best games I've ever
received this weekend my friend gave me
a pair of these shoes they're called the
so-and-so Cloud lifters oh yeah they're
like male high heels
and they add three inches to your height
so for a night oh I've I think I've seen
from for one night I was six feet tall
why didn't you wear them did you
actually what did you see it did yeah
because I was like I need I need to see
how this feels but the problem is
everybody else got a pair too so my
friends and I were all just the same
height to each other so it kind of just
felt the same yeah the boys got the
heels now and we did finally no longer a
meme it's [ __ ] up though that's like
uh
oh that's [ __ ] up yeah well you'd be
like walk out to somebody imagine like
courting somebody right you bring it
back and you're like oh yeah yeah it's a
little like yeah you're definitely
catfishing it reminds me of every single
dude in those trying to get crushing
what you're hype fishing yeah well the
original form of that in New York was
like Tim boots those add three inches
because bro because in this case it was
the soul was huge or I mean the heel of
the shoe was huge but then also the soul
inside was another like I feel like Air
Maxes kind of act as that too a little
bit Yeah but these are you're like no no
yours are like they're like you actually
legit like get like much taller yes like
Air Maxes like when I put my Air Maxes
on I know that I'm like noticeably
taller yeah that's true and [ __ ] or same
like like boots or whatever too but yeah
Tim boots I think give you at least like
an inch and a half okay that's the
original hype fish but I think like
and this actually could be one of the
reasons why my back is so [ __ ] up a
thousand percent because I'm like it
felt like I was walking on my toes the
entire night
ow
L now all the women are gonna reply yeah
wearing heels isn't so [ __ ] easy is
it I never said it was yeah it would be
sweet to just be
six two yeah it felt felt good I gotta
be honest I'm six one so almost there
yeah but my doctor says I got a couple
more growth spurts in me yeah
yeah where and like in like your thighs
and your it's true my skin is very
elastic so you have room to grow at all
times
[Music]
man I wish you wore the cloud lifts
today I would have liked to see it I
know they were like destroyed
because you were just you were just
gloving so hard did you actually like
[ __ ] them up yeah they're all dirty oh I
see just for one one night just dirty
got it yeah they got all [ __ ] up they
that must have been nice white ones at
the bar trying to get a drink you
weren't like the little [ __ ] Hobbit
oh yeah I was May I get a beer fully
I'll have a Modelo yeah
that's not what the cool kids drink now
modelos yeah can I get a glass of milk
no one's even said anything that I'm
rocking some air monarchs
those are fire
I hear they're coming back these are
actually the most comfortable shoes I've
ever worn in my life haven't we talked
about this before have we we might have
talked about this on me like let me talk
about Meat Locker oh did we yeah I think
we talk about your feets on me oh hey
you'll have to wait till Monday right
yeah go ahead and kick him dude kick him
again guess what this was 35 yeah
I I needed to just stock up on them
because I think that we're going to run
out there's going to be a mass shortage
of air monarchs I think Payless has a
[ __ ] Warehouse of those and you are
good for the rest of your life I doubt
it we'll see we'll see as soon as kids
start thinking things are cool
guess what out of stock everywhere yeah
it's been mowing in their air monarchs
for the past 30 years yeah they're gonna
be pissed everybody go buy up the Air
Monarch Supply and put 35 run it up get
them while you can I bet you by the end
by the end of the year which is a month
these things are going to be worth 105
dollars you think
nah all right all this [ __ ] you know
what dude I say what I say and I mean
what I say
right yeah
yeah
okay
all right well guess what we'll start
[ __ ] looking keep keep track that's
all I gotta say yeah is that price gonna
hold probably not but I expect actually
you know what we'll just buy them all
yeah that's fine we'll buy them all we
could buy up this remaining stock of
those easily yep